Brady has started a new video channel
about words and one of the words is
vodka and he's challenged me to say
something chemical about vodka it's
really too easy but I'll do it all the
same the first thing which some of you
may have seen on our other videos is
that Mendeleev father of the periodic
table worked out the method of measuring
the standard concentration of alcohol in
vodka at about 40 percent so you can buy
vodka with Mendeleev's name on it and
the periodic table and I keep this
bottle in my office to drink when
something sad happens friend dies or the
grant is not funded here's a picture of
Mendel life on my tie in some parts of
Russia he's more famous for vodka than
he was for the periodic table a few
years ago I found this bottle of vodka
in France
it has Polyakov which is my surname so I
was quite excited but it's belt with a V
rather than a double F the way I spell
it because over the years the way that
people translate the Russian and
alphabet into English letters has
changed but it's the same name don't
know if it's as good as the Mendeleev
one but the real scientific reason that
I can talk about vodka is with this
bottle of Stoli Geno means capital vodka
which you can see is empty and the
reason it's empty is because the vodka
in this bottle was used by one of my
students
Sasha Nowitzki in an experiment we had
invented a new way of measuring the
phase behavior that is to find when you
heat up a liquid when it goes into a gas
and we've measured invented way for
measuring the phase behavior of mixtures
of alcohol and water and when we were
preparing the paper to publish Sasha
said it'd be really nice to try
a mixture of real mixture of alcohol and
water vodka so we did the experiment and
it worked and here you can see the
scientific paper and here is the phase
diagram of Stella's no vodka as a
function of temperature and pressure it
worked really quite well except we
forgot that vodka also contains a small
amount of sugar and at the high
temperature the sugar turned to caramel
and by the end of the experiment the
whole apparatus was blocked I should
just say that vodkas played quite a role
in my life
one of the first poems that I ever
learned in Russian was about vodka it
went to Jacques Patrick de Bona fontanka
vodka pol we belong to people via a
chanel of galava little sparrow little
sparrow where've you been I've been on
the front incur a river in st.
Petersburg and I was drinking vodka I
drank one little glass then another and
now annoys has started in my head and if
you want to find out more about vodka or
samovar or lots of other words go and
see Brady's website it's quite fun I've
learned quite a lot already and I'm sure
you will too is it better than periodic
table of videos well that I would not
want to be judgmental about my
colleagues